What did you do to me?
Your body won't last long in,
stuck in there for the rest of your
life.
You'll get me out of here.
You son of up and down her cat.
I hate cats.
Crappy movies suck.
Obviously.
I hate to waste my money or my time on
something that is truly bad like suicide
squad,
that where every decision seems to be
made for maximum shit.
He tells me a whole lot.
It's a shame,
but in the end,
I think crappy movies are an inevitable
part of the cinematic ecosystem.
You're not ever going to get away from
them and whether or not they make money,
some of which unfortunately do.
No one is setting out to make a movie
that is a piece of crap.
I'm talking about a completely plus
bottle
cough syrup.
That's like six bucks.
What's more insidious in my opinion,
are movies that are just passable.
Films just good enough not to be
terrible.
I mean passable films,
they aren't bad.
They might even be better than okay,
but there are a far cry from great or
noteworthy or something that you would
like to see more than once that the
cinematic equivalent of this image,
they don't fall apart,
but their balance is always precarious.
In the last handful of years,
my annoyance with passable movies has
steadily increased in proportion with
their steadily increasing number.
Passable films like to multiply.
They do just enough for the audience and
just enough for the studio and just
enough for the stars.
They have no problem being funded.
Stop,
stop.
I need to know what is happening right
now.
For a long time,
I've attributed the major problem with
passable movies to a lack of tonal
control.
The emotional logic of the narrative in
films like these often often feels a bit
out of whack either.
The film tries to be too many things at
once leading to unintended emotional
confusion.
Don Friends as well,
Governor Nix this unit has been
authorized,
is pristinely.
That's enough.
That's enough
for the filmmakers.
Give characters traits that don't belong
to them in order to serve some plot
function.
What has it been this they're so fun to
watch without the end?
Many millions of people with no what and
that's just the first two weeks of
January or emotional arcs initiated
early in the story are abandoned without
comment,
often proving in the end to be entirely
pointless in good movies.
Everything points to everything else.
Emotional arcs of the characters,
the scenes,
the imagery,
the music and the plot are tightly
entwined and this doesn't just go for
high brow movies by the way,
whenever you hear someone say,
have a lower brow film that it knows
what it is.
What they're really saying is that the
film was totally focused,
but recently I've begun to notice
another unifying feature of passable
movies.
Indeed,
of all passable storytelling and to
understand what I mean,
take a look at.
I gotta say feels really good to have
somebody looking out for me.
I got your back.
I like that,
and I got your back too.
Hey Doug.
I like you man.
Thank you.
A great guy.
I just want you to remember that this is
a business relationship.
Doesn't mean that we're going to be best
friends.
That's not how this story is just an
employee with a job to do.
I got it.
My best friend,
and you're just my best man.
It doesn't mean that we're not going to
have a good time though I sat,
I got it.
You're anybody's best friend for price,
but nobody's winning account.
All the beats in the short scene should
be familiar to us.
We've seen them all before,
but there's something odd going on here.
See,
stories are almost always about people
or aliens or gods or animals or robots
that act like people and great stories
are always the ones that observed people
truthfully,
the ones that capture human experience
with nuance and insight and the best
stories make such acute observations
about humanity that they can show us
things about ourselves that we didn't
know or teach us how to articulate those
things against a vast unintelligible
anxiety,
and this I think is the big difference
between great movies and passable ones.
When passable movies observe human
experience,
they observe it not through the lens of
real life,
but through the lens of other movies.
Love is my life.
No love is your job.
No,
I think you're threatened by what zoe
and I have because you're afraid I won't
be able to hang out every night.
You were my drug dealer.
There's one reason we know each other.
I like the drugs you sell.
That's it.
There is this huge library,
this huge vocabulary of actions built up
over the years that people you know
don't really do,
but which happens so often in TV and
movies that they're familiar enough to
an audience that they become well
passable for human motivations.
I'm not saying it's bad for filmmakers
to site or pay homage to the movies that
they love in their own work.
I'm saying that too many films released
today are being cobbled together from a
weird alternate reality that is only a
dim echo of our own.
It does not believe in fairy tales about
Chakras or energy with a power belief.
There is no such thing as spirit.
This is the longterm danger of cliche.
The more we allow it to happen,
the harder it is to escape,
the more difficult it is for audiences
and writers to tell the difference.
The last thing we want is to see our own
lives through the Lens of art.
That's only passable.
New perspectives are what we need.
Originality is what we should encourage
you at every chance.
Otherwise,
I'm afraid our movies and ourselves will
change into something quite different.
What's it called?
The imitation game.
There is a new nerdwriter episode.
Every Wednesday.
Guys will be click that box that I've
set up for you right over there.
You'll get a.
you'll get the videos,
you'll get up,
you'll get all the videos.
Did you hit that little bell on mobile?
I think you get notified when I release
something new,
so we do that too.
Thanks to squarespace for sponsoring
this video.
They make sleek,
intuitive website designs for you to
customize and you don't have to know
coding to make a really beautiful one.
Um,
if you sign up for a year,
you can get a free domain name and if
you use the offer code nerdwriter,
you can get 10 percent off your first
purchase.
So that's pretty cool.
Thank you so much.
I will see the arrest of view next
Wednesday.
I was a weird and scream,
I think I'm going to use it.